The abstractions that the transport layer provides are endpoint,
transport, channel, and connection. And I'll talk
about each of these things in a little
bit more detail. Endpoint you can think of
as nothing but a protection domain or you can say it is a Java virtual machine.
And it has a table of remote objects that it can access. And so this gives
you a protection domain or a sandbox for execution of a server cord or
a client cord can exist within the sandbox. That's what end point. Its basically
a protection domain. Connection management, is the
interesting piece that is what is about
all the details of connecting these end
points together. And in particular, the connection management
of the transport layer of the Java Runtime system is responsible for setting up
connections, tearing down connections, listening for incoming
connections, and establishing the connection. And when a
connection is established. Between two end points
there's a distraction that I mentioned called
transport comes into play. So, for instant
between this end point, and this end point,
thec connection manager decided to have udp
transport. So a channel is established between this
end point and this end point to do
udp transport between these two end points. And
so this is the functionality of the UDP
transport that is incorporated in this transport layer.
And similarly, between this endpoint and this endpoint,
the connection manager decided to use a TCP
channel, so the transport that is being used
here is a TCP connection, both ends. We have
a TCB connection at both ends to connecting
this endpoint with this endpoint. Notice that a given
endpoint, can have different transport for talking to
different endpoints depending on a variety of parameters. What
is the best way for this endpoint to talk
to this endpoint may decide what kind of connection.
This end point is going to establish with this end point. That is all part of
connection management that is happening in the transport
layer of the Java run time. And the
connection manager is also responsible for locating the
dispatcher for a remote method that is being invoked on this end point.
So. A transport is listening on a channel. And when
an invocation comes in, then this transport
is responsible for identifying, or locating, the dispatcher
on this domain, which will know how to
carry out that invocation. And the connection managers
also responsible for managing the liveness of the
connection. Because, if any point goes away, it
needs to know that and inform this domain
that, oh this particular end point is gone.
So, take the appropriate action. So that kind of liveness monitoring is part of
connection management. So the last abstraction I
mentioned is the notion of connection itself.
So once a channel has been established. Then the transport can do IO on
this channel using connections. So, the path
for the transport layer is in connection management.
It listens for an incoming request. When
an incoming request comes in. It then establishes
a channel, and the channel that is established
for communication, which is a mutual agreement between
these two endpoints. It choses a transport
that is most appropriate for that and once
the channel has been established, a connection. Is
now made between this endpoint and this endpoint
through this channel. And now these two endpoints
can do I/O on the channel using the
connection. So that's how the transport mechanism of
RMI works. As we saw, the transport mechanism sits
below the RRL layer. And so it allows
all the object invocations to happen through the
transport layer. And the RRL layer is the
one that is deciding, what are the right transport
to use depending on the location of the
two endpoints, where the client is and where
the server is. Depending on that, it might
decide what would be the right transport to use.
Whether it should use TCP or UDP and
so on. And gives that command to the connection
manager which is part of the transport layer
of the software stack. So that the established channel
can be established and then a connection can be used for actual transport. Of
the implementation between the client and server.
So in summary, the distributed object model of
Java is a powerful vehicle for constructing
network services and what we say in this
lesson. Is a glimpse of the classes
that are available in the distributed object model
that makes the life of the developer
easy in terms of creating network objects and
making it visible for clients to use anywhere. And the power of the RRL layer in
dynamically deciding how to make the client-server relationship.
Similar to the sub contract mechanism that we
saw in spring and we also saw the
flexibility in the connection management. Allowing different kinds
of transport exist between the client and the server depending on
the location of the client and network conditions and so on.